[Music]
this is my family and i will not let you
take me away from them
here
[Music]
a toast to motherhood
and to new beginnings
i think that everything's happening the
way that it's supposed to
this cult could come back for her at any
time none of you can protect me from
them
you wouldn't even know what to look for
are you feeding those squatters again
sean my hungry kids dorothy
what if they're casing the place
i forbid you to go back to that park so
funny how controlling you can be
i think would be best for everyone if
you were able to make peace with leanne
why aren't you so afraid of her
she's angry
please don't hurt her
julian you're not telling me everything
what is going on
what the hell happens now
the end
i don't want to lose my son again
things are decaying
this is my family
and i will not let you take me away from
them
god didn't bring back jericho
and who did
[Music]
it all must make sense there has to be a
reason things don't just happen
[Music]
we pick up three months later and leanne
is in the middle of absolute paranoia i
told you that we can't trust strangers
she's anticipating an attack that hasn't
happened yet
you ready for food buddy num num time on
the surface you really get a sense that
the family's doing well i thought you
want to see this
[Music]
i think the family has been lulled into
thinking we made it i think that
everything's happening the way that it's
supposed to
don't worry
and dorothy's very grateful
that she has her child back she's very
sympathetic
to leanne as a teenage member of a cult
[Music]
but can you leave the church can you
leave this cult i just want to
understand what you believe
that's all when leanne starts exhibiting
darker tendencies and destructive
choices believe me i am frightened about
what she might do next dorothy is a
realization that she's dealing with
someone really really unstable
each character in the family has their
own point of view about what's happening
sean believes that this is a miracle and
leanne is the instrument of that i still
can't believe we're here
on the other side of it
julian is a person that struggles with
addiction in many forms and in this
season his addiction is leanne
leanne continually starts to surprise
herself then her
realization of how powerful she is grows
to a
scary and very dark place
god won't fix you
there's a defiant part of her that's
going to emerge and it will get kind of
scary when she's pushed too far
i'm doing this for you
fans of servant will find
that
we found our stride
the story kind of keeps unfolding and
you're going to learn more and more
about the mystery the things you've been
waiting to hear about and there's so
many shocks and surprises there's life
and death every single episode season
three should leave your jaw hanging open
[Music]
you